now Biden has still not been there I'm
going to show you a clip on buying And
discussing this in just a second but why
is it that when gay Pete showed up two
days later after Trump and Trump got an
incredibly wonderful warm Ovation Pete
did not and he shows up in his little
hat and his vest and he pretends he
knows what he's doing and all of that
stuff and nobody's happy that he's there
why is it that he wasn't able to show up
with I don't know 20 million bucks
not 117 billion a lot of zeros but uh
how about 20 million bucks we're going
to help you guys figure this out but he
couldn't do that
very very curious and Biden has no plans
on going because he sent the EPA as if
the EPA does absolutely anything take a
look
it's been three weeks now since the
toxic train derailment in East Palestine
Ohio as you know the mayor says he saw
you in Ukraine and he says it tells you
he doesn't care about us they're asking
is the President coming to Ohio
do you have any plan to travel to Ohio
and have you talked with the mayor yet
let's put this in perspective within two
hours
of that derailment the EPA was in there
within two hours
every major agency in the United States
government that had anything to do with
Rail and or cleanup was there and is
there in addition to that I've spoken at
length to the congresspersons the
governors the senators from both states
of Pennsylvania and and in Ohio
and I've made it clear to them anything
they need is available we'll make it
available to them whatever happens here
we've got to understand is the
responsibility of the railroad company
who's made by the way tens of billions
of dollars in profits tens of billions
of dollars of profits lately so do you
plan to travel there and have you talked
with the mayor I I can't recall that I
don't think I've talked to the mayor
I've talked to everyone else there
multiple times talked to both the
Senators both Governors I've talked to
everyone there to talk to and we made it
clear that everything is available he's
completely missing the point I accept
that the EPA was there I don't know that
the two-hour thing was right and I
certainly doubt that every agency that
would be involved in something of this
magnitude was there in two hours but
let's say they all got there within 24
hours I'm not even sure that's true but
I'll in this case I'm going to Grant him
a Long Leash on this one that's fine and
let's hope they're doing the appropriate
work I don't really think that they are
they're telling people literally to
drink the tap water meanwhile JD Vance
senator from Ohio is out there with a
stick in the river showing that there's
there is glowing goo basically in the
water that feeds 10 percent of the
United States but let's just assume
Biden is telling you the truth on all of
that he's still missing the point which
is why don't you show up that there are
a good amount of people in the United
States of America who think that you Joe
Biden don't care about America you care
about spending more time giving money to
people overseas for their Adventures
rather than just showing up
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]